well that's what we are trying to find
now uh
the more we get the more information we
get
about the balance whether they are dead
or alive
and where they are and the important
thing about
uh insisting on the
in in in betweens going in between
especially ngos from united nations is
the credibility of persons
that will be talking the federal
government so clearly there are
negotiations happening between
executive government and boko haram what
was boko haram given in exchange for the
release of the girls
this one i don't know until i go back i
said
they were released on the morning i left
and this is not something we will
discuss on the telephone
until i go back i will receive a formal
briefing
on how the negotiations went because the
situation
was very unclear from the nigerian
government side there were reports that
four boko haram leaders had been
released
and then there were counter reports from
the governments that said that this was
not the case well
you see ahead of me this one i'll go
back i'll find out
the written uh confirmation of
how it all went now one of your big
election pledges
was to tackle corruption and this drive
has seen you jailed
judges and police chiefs even your own
former national security
adviser what was the problem as you saw
it
with corruption in nigeria
well um i think i'll tell you what we'll
clearly understand
um the foreign companies especially
oil infrastructure and development
companies have been in nigeria for our
two generations
40 years and above and so on so they
know the environment
they know the the state that
long they continue to invest because
they know
the potentialities nigeria has in oil
and
gas and the capacity of their
people to learn and work hard
that's that's why they they are still
prospecting uh in nigeria and so on but
the thing the nigerian government will
do
is to secure the environment unless the
environment is secured
then unfortunately the investments
wouldn't be coming in
now recently um your wife criticized
your choices for top jobs and you
responded by saying
i don't know which party my wife belongs
to but she belongs to my kitchen and my
living room
what did you mean by that sir
i'm sure you have a house you know where
your kitchen is you know where your
living room is yes
and i believe you are always look after
that even if you
like it and so that is that is your
wife's function
it is too yes